marie this laurent bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france alors vous êtes
l'une des 300 avocats présents au procès
pour défendre une victime directe des
attentats pour commencer la personne que
vous représentez pour ce procès qu'est
ce qu'elle a vécu ce 13 novembre qu'est
ce qu'elle vit aujourd'hui
eh bien ma clients se trouvaient aux
abords du stade de france
ce soir là lorsqu'un commando s'est fait
exploser dans son dos donc il y a des
blessures physiques gravissimes sur
nécessité plus d'un an d'hospitalisation
et des séquelles psychologiques
aujourd'hui encore extrêmement vive
alors c'est vous qui allez porter cette
histoire donc pendant ces neuf mois de
procès dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes
aujourd'hui
eh bien je suis
je suis fier d'avoir la chance
que ma cliente me fasse cette confiance
mais au regard des enjeux de ce procès
il y a aussi un petit sentiment de petit
sentiment de peur parce que finalement
on ne sait pas encore à quoi s'attendre
alors en tout cas la cour d'assises
spéciale elle doit juger au total 20
accusés à l'ouverture de l'audience
c'est sans doute vers salle abdeslam que
tous les regards se tourneront pour le
moment il a refusé de parler qu'est ce
que vous attendez de lui qu'est ce que
la personne que vous présentez les
victimes en général attentes de salah
abdeslam il doit parler
alors oui bien sûr on aimerait tous
qu'ils parlent mais pour le moment on
regarde l'état actuel du dossier c'est
pas le choix qu'il a fait donc en tout
état de cause qu'il parle qu'il ne parle
pas il faudra trouver des réponses elles
viendront peut-être de l'enquète qui
sera étudiée dans le détail à l'audience
mais les victimes ont besoin non
seulement de mettre des visages sur
leurs blessures mais aussi de comprendre
comment on a pu en arriver là quels sont
justement les réponses que vous attend
dès aujourd'hui
eh bien elles sont elles sont multiples
je dirais que la première j'ai envie de
comprendre le contexte comment des
jeunes hommes en sont venus à tuer a tué
la jeunesse parisienne
ce soir là il y a aussi les services de
renseignement belges et français on en
parlait et on a vu qu'il ya eu un manque
de communication entre les services de
renseignement cette question elle doit
être expert si également
toute question qui seraient susceptibles
pour le moment de générer des doutes ou
un flou devra être évoquée à cette
audience oui parce que qu'est-ce que
vous attendez de la justice comment
réparer au mieux finalement si on peut
réparer toutes ces blessures de la
victime que vous représentez
alors on essaiera de réparer ce procès
c'est une première étape à mon sens dans
un processus de reconstruction des
victimes le chemin sera encore long et
là la première étape pour les pour les
victimes en tout cas pour celles que je
représente ça va être déjà d'être
entendu d'être reconnu en qualité de
victime et de pouvoir expliquer aux
magistrats ce qui lui est arrivé ce
vendredi 13 ce procès il suscite bien
évidemment une attention médiatique
immense mais est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que que loin des projecteurs
finalement la parole des victimes est
suffisamment entendu
l'accompagnement des victimes sur le
long terme plus gerald généralement
est-ce qu'il est suffisamment prises en
charge en france
on côté pour ce dossier j'ai
l'impression mais j'ai pas encore assez
de assez de recul pour me prononcer sur
une telle question très concrètement
pour revenir peut-être sur la forme sur
ce procès il débute aujourd'hui il va
durer neuf mois comment ça va se passer
pour les victimes pour vous qui
représentez une victime directe
et bien à l'heure actuelle on a un
calendrier prévisionnel qui nous a été
transmis par le président on nous
conseille que à partir de la
mi-septembre les victimes vont être
entendus et ce sont les victimes du
stade de france qui parleront en premier
donc ma cliente elle sera entendue à la
fin à la fin du mois de septembre donc
ça va nécessiter qu'on continue ensemble
à travailler sur sur son audition
avant avant le jour j bien évidemment
les les plaidoiries seront elles à la
fin au printemps et entre temps seront
entendus devant la cour d'assises
spéciale des témoins étaient moins clés
et des victimes en fonction des
différents lieux des attaques justement
comment est ce que vous vous préparer
cette audition de votre cliente qu'elle
est quelle est votre relation
aujourd'hui
et bien c'est une cliente a à qui j'ai
dit on pouvait s'appeler jours et demi
c'est un travail de libération de la
parole qui a nécessité plusieurs mois de
rendez-vous d'appels téléphoniques et
je les écoute on va dire quasiment tous
les jours on se parle quotidiennement
aujourd'hui elle sera bien évidemment
présente à l'ouverture des débats
et on a en plus d'être des avocats et
des juristes on a un rôle d'accompagnant
et surtout d' écoute dans un tel dans un
tel dossier pour conclure cet
accompagnement il l'a transformé votre
regard sur la justice votre façon de
travailler
oui oui parce que même si je suis
habitué à la matière pénale
j'avais jamais encore eu de dossier qui
traitait du terrorisme donc j'ai pu
avoir un dossier exceptionnelle et hors
normes donc ça m'a peut-être que ça m'a
fait mûrir professionnellement
certainement
merci beaucoup à vous marrez this
laurent d'avoir accepté de répondre à
nos questions ce matin sur rtl francs je
le rappelle vous êtes avocat au barreau
de paris et et vous défendez un l'une
des victimes directes des attentats du
13 novembre